ne m'appelez plus jamais arjowiggins est
ma dernière volonté ah ben oui là oui
parce que c'est
c'est ce qu'on a vécu ce qu'ont vécu and
broad 1 et 5 169 autres salariés c'est
la fermeture d'arjowiggins une usine de
papier
implanté depuis près de deux siècles à
bessé sur braye village de 2200
habitants pour de nombreux salariés les
dirigeants n'ont rien fait pour éviter
le naufrage pire il l'aurait provoqué
peut-être qu'on se trompe mais on est
persuadé que c'était volontaire la fin
de cette usine
elle n'a pas pour nous aller c'est pas
qu'elle n'est pas justifié c'est vrai
que le marché de dupes à pied était en
déclin c'est vrai mais là il ya eu des
choses qu'on n'explique pas et qu'on ne
nous explique pas et on se dit que c'est
c'est vraiment la volonté de quelqu'un à
55 ans et après 28 ans de bons et loyaux
services and bredin s'interroge sur son
avenir professionnel
optimiste elle reste toutefois réaliste
sur ses chances de retrouver un emploi
je vais réussir à m'occuper à titre
personnel par contre financièrement
parlant c'est ça va pas aller du tout
parce que j'ai droit qu'à deux ans et
demi de chômage et que si je né sais que
55 ans donc la retraite ce sera 62 là je
ne peux pas l'envisager ça
je peux pas l'envisager jeu faudra que
je trouve n'importe quelle solution pour
pour travailler un minimum parce que
alors peut-être à mi temps peut-être je
sais pas mais c'est pour moi c'est pas
possible de m'imaginer ne pas retrouver
de travail alors déménagé alors après
c'est encore autre chose je peux moment
je veux pas y penser non plus parce que
je me plais ici mais peut-être que je
serais obligé quand on est senior et
femmes c'est peut-être encore plus
compliqué parce que il ya des postes
pour les hommes qui ont retrouvé en tant
que menuisier en tant que soudeur et ce
à une femme c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pourquoi l'état n'est-il pas
intervenu c'est l'une des questions
cliente and broad 1 pour elle les
ex-salariés ont été abandonnés par les
pouvoirs publics
quand on a les anciennetés que la grande
majorité des salariés avaient oui on est
on est écoeuré en écoeuré on est
dégoûtés par le système s'est pas
pensable que l'état ne fasse rien pour
on a vu des politiques on avait beaucoup
de politiques mais il n'y a rien eu de
fait vraiment mais on se demande
pourquoi pourquoi n'y a rien de fait
pour soutenir
est ce que l'état aurait pu faire
quelque chose nous nous pensons que oui
parce qu'il a payé
des millions des millions pour fermer
l'usiné
les licenciements ont coûté énormément
d'argent il aurait mieux fallu donner
les millions et profère partir lusine
quoi un espoir demeure malgré tout pour
les anciens salariés de cette entreprise
un plan pour faire redémarrer cette
usine de papier pour cela ils ont besoin
d'un industriel capable d'investir
plusieurs millions d'euros pas une mince
affaire mais pas impossible non plus and
broad ans et plusieurs anciens de ses
collègues veulent toujours y croire
[Musique]